l'élégance ce fut le maître mots d'yves
saint laurent en 40 ans de création et
c'est avec la même élégance que le plus
grand couturier français a annoncé son
départ ce matin quelques mots sincères
et beaucoup d'émotion pour celui qui a
toujours défendu une certaine idée de la
femme sans céder justement aux toutes
dernières modes sabine gorny le quai de
riches l'arrivée discrète du maître des
lieux dans sa chair maison culture là où
depuis 40 ans et fabriqué la légende et
ce matin les choeurs sont serrés
l'émotion palpable
costume noir comme une histoire monsieur
saint laurent dit au revoir
j'ai choisi aujourd'hui de dire adieu à
ce métier peser tant aimée c'est aussi à
ses fantômes d'esthétique mais je dis à
dieu je vais connais depuis mon enfance
de ses pour les retrouver que je choisis
ce merveilleux métier
quelques lignes lue avec pudeur et
dignité pour dire cette vie pleine de la
joie de créer plein d'angoissé d'un
génie tourmenté inquiet tout entier au
service de la beauté
un texte pour dire merci aux fidèles
atelier à la famille à pierre bergé le
pygmalion l'ami de toujours celui avec
qui l'histoire de la maison se devait de
s'achever
comme elle avait commencé
il a pris sa décision seul calmement et
je trouve que ça manque de respect
d'avoir ça et que ça atténue beaucoup
beaucoup la tristesse
beaucoup savent et c'est un petit chez
d'un village a été commencée il ya 40
ans se termine sans bavure
j'ai conscience d'avoir fait progresser
la mode de mon temps et d'avoir permis
aux femmes d'accéder à un univers
jusqu'à les voluptés la haute couture ou
l'art du sur mesure pour des clients de
fortune est prête à payer très cher le
prix de l'exclusivité saint-laurent s'en
va une maison disparaît avec tout le
savoir faire des ateliers
je suis bouleversée quand même parce que
je n'y croyais je voulais pas y croire
je ne voulais pas croire qu'un artiste
génial 16h02 créé en fait c'est comme
comme un père comme j'ai pas dit oui
c'est vrai je suis triste aussi pour lui
parce que bus pour lui que pour tout le
monde aussi ça va aujourd'hui c'est
parce qu'il a ce sentiment de n'être
plus à plaindre vers le monde qu'il ne
pourra pas car la mode appartient
désormais aux financiers en 99 françois
pinault racheter la maison saint laurent
et en confier le prêt-à-porter un texan
tom ford
pour yves saint laurent il fallait
accepter que son nom sa griffe soit
désormais aussi la signature d'un autre
ce prince de l'élégance a préféré
s'éclipser injuste
chaleureux et d'où on a l'impression
qu'il referme doucement la porte voilà
monsieur saint-laurent jette le des
seuls couturier avoir ouvert et fermé sa
maison de son plein gré en toute liberté